à thomas qu'elle accueille ce matin pour
le président français après l'échec des
négociations hier et avant-hier sur le
budget européen et la pac notamment le
président de la république a été
interpellé dès son arrivée ici au salon
l'agriculture il est très attendu ou
imaginées par les agriculteurs qui sont
présents ici pour qui les motifs
d'inquiétude sont nombreux il ya
évidemment la pac le budget de la pac
dont vous avez parlé avec l'échec des
négociations hier à bruxelles macron
attentes et donc de rassurer les
agriculteurs présents ici mais il ya un
tas d'autres sujets pour lesquels il ya
des inquiétudes notamment sur les
viticulteurs qui craignent les taxes de
donald trump ou sur le vin français mais
aussi les traiter les décrets anti
pesticides qui sont pris ici ou là par
certains élus c'est sur ce thème que
macron a été interpellé ce matin par des
agriculteurs membres du principal
syndicat agricole fnsea
un échange plutôt cordiale je vous
propose d'écouter sachez que monde
agricole est à l'écouté de la société
mais pas des apprentis sorciers on n'est
pas des gens qui fait n'importe où mais
avant tout on est il ya des mères de
famille des pères de famille aussi ce
qu'on fait et on respecte nos voisins et
la société par contre aujourd'hui
comment vous pouvez sortir des choses
comme ça sans qu'on parle de
compensation on va avoir des écarts en
moi il ya des gens qui se posent des
questions à savoir comment ils vont
vivre
on sait que le monde agricole passe des
moments difficiles niveau niveau
économique
voilà on attend des réponses là dessus
autrement je suis désolé va y avoir une
cassure entre vous et nous et j'en suis
désolé
ce à quoi je tiens c'est ce sur quoi on
s'est engagés tous ensemble c'est à dire
la baisse des pesticides
la sortie du glyphosate avec la formule
sur laquelle je me suis engagé dès le
début pas d'interdiction sans solution
la vérité n'est pas de bonne solution
moi ce que ce à quoi je veux qu'on
arrive c'est que on ne disent pas et on
ne fasse pas croire aux riverains qui
sont de bonne foi
on cache le sujet qu'on le traitement
s'est donc dit non mais j'ai dit à mes
sacs en exercerait beau c'est pour ça
que je suis en train de vous dire c'est
bien la science presse la science il
faut trouver la bonne méthode
même à cran qui va par la suite
rencontré les éleveurs là où on se
trouve notamment auprès des éleveurs
bovins là aussi il ya des inquiétudes
sur l'évolution du métier d'éleveur mais
macron qui va donc rester un certain
nombre de temps ici du côté l'elysée on
nous annonce qu'il ne sera pas question
pour bien la con de rester aussi
longtemps qu'il l'a fait les années
précédentes on se souvient que l'an
dernier même de macron était resté au
salon de l'agriculture
14h ce qui constituait un record pour un
président de la république devrait
rester un peu moins longtemps
aujourd'hui puis à noter enfin que des
gilets jaunes ont lancé des appels à
manifester que ce soit devant le salon
de la porte de versailles où on se
trouve ou à l'intérieur de ce salon de
l'agriculture c'est peut-être une des
raisons qui explique la très forte
présence des forces de l'ordre ici pour
ce 57e salon de l'agriculture
merci thomas bonnin en direct du salon
de l'agriculture au parc des expositions